hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be taking a deep dive into the latest
events in the black clover story
including the reveal of yuno's
incredible and incredibly overpowered
second magic his original magic which i
think could basically be kryptonite for
devils yuno's original magic is angelic
and celestial in nature and so it is the
polar opposite of devil magic and this
could be the key to stopping the
strongest devils at the very lowest
floors of the cliff off so let's get
into it if you enjoy these black clover
videos and you want to see more in the
future you know what to do just leave a
quick like and comment it's a totally
free way to directly support the channel
and of course if you're new here or if
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
it would help us out a lot if you made
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now as you will recall in
the previous chapter we got the massive
twist that yuno has a second magic
attribute his original magic from the
spade kingdom which was finally unlocked
when the grimoire that was meant for him
recognized him inside the palace but the
previous chapter did not reveal what
yuno's second magic attribute was all we
saw was a pillar of light descending
from the sky and i was speculating that
it might be some kind of light magic as
it turns out i was right yeah i don't
care what anyone says i was right okay
yes yuno's magic turned out to be star
magic which is far more rare and epic
than regular light magic but stars
technically produce light so i'm gonna
take that w anyway moving on as you know
star magic begins to manifest four
majestic stars begin floating around
yuno and then several beams of light
begin to pierce xenon and absolutely
obliterate the parts of his body that
they came into contact with xenon has no
idea what's going on at first why does
this guy have two grimoires and such
powerful magic that he didn't exhibit
before and that is when we get the story
of the royal family of the spade kingdom
and their special magic it seems that
for many generations the house grin
burial has passed on similar special
types of magic all of which seem to be
based on celestial bodies so yuno's
father loys had sun magic as in he was
literally escanor and yuno's mother ciel
had moon magic xenon then realizes who
you know must be he is the heir to the
throne the child of the house grinberry
all and he possesses star magic looking
upon the newly powered up you know a
blushing sylph says that she feels like
she's just met the real you know by
which he means that this is yuno at his
full potential yuno with the power of
his original magic at his disposal
however yuno tells self that even with
this new power he cannot win alone and
he asks her to activate spirit dive one
more time as his spirit dive form
appears yuno tells langers and funeral
to retreat and seek medical help while
he handles the rest and i have to say
that this is a very fitting moment kudos
to funeral and language for holding out
as long as they did against xenon and
for buying yuno the time he needed to
recover his original magic but yuno has
to be the one to take xenon on it just
makes a lot more sense not only did
xenon kill yuno's comrades from the
golden dawn but he was also responsible
for the murder of juno's parents and for
the destruction of his entire royal
bloodline and he is also responsible for
tyrannically mistreating the citizens of
the spade kingdom the very people that
you know as the true heir to the throne
is responsible for protecting so xenon
really is yuno's arch nemesis in this
series and logically yuno should be the
one to take him down we were all
wondering how that would even be
possible especially after xenon's latest
devil heart power up but it looks like
we just got our answer with star magic
not only is this magic incredibly rare
and powerful but i think that it's also
super effective against devils the
devil's kryptonite stars are associated
with the heavenly realm with angels and
divine beings and they are the polar
opposites of hell and devils it is said
that in the bible stars are symbols of
the angels and fallen angels like satan
were cast out of heaven and down to
earth so they are fallen stars in that
sense yuno's new magic may be a brand
new magic subgroup angel magic or
celestial magic which is super effective
against devils honestly with all the
overpowered devils that are still
waiting to emerge from the cliff off we
actually needed another form of magic
that is highly effective against devils
yes dark magic is effective but yami is
imprisoned and anti-magic is effective
but asta can't do everything alone so
you know having star magic magic from
the heavens is actually kind of perfect
it creates a battle between heaven and
hell and it allows yuno to keep up with
asta once more during the climax of this
arc
back to the fight xenon attempts to
attack yuno with his bone tentacles but
you know star magic is able to easily
negate all of his attacks xenon even
attempts to trap yuno inside one of his
spatial magic cubes but yuno easily
breaks through it and he seems to be
able to teleport instantly from one
place to another as long as one of his
stars is located at the point of origin
and another one is at the destination
point that is at least my interpretation
of how his power seems to work if he's
standing below one star he can just
instantly teleport below another and if
that is the case it is of course super
op and it is the perfect counter to
xenon spatial magic yuno then destroys
an entire side of xenon's upper body
with a powerful beam produced by star
magic he also declares that the pages of
his grimoire were engraved to defeat
xenon as if defeating xenon is his very
destiny and again this makes me think
that there is something special about
star magic something that makes it
basically kryptonite for devils and the
way that yuno is just demolishing xenon
right now despite xenon's devil heart
power up seems to suggest that this
could be true the intense battle
continues for some time and the chapter
ends as juno's sword clashes with the
bone of xenon sword i mean the bone
sword that xenon uses you know vows that
he will save the spade kingdom and that
he is the one who will be victorious
although xenon seems to share that exact
determination on his end as well and
that is how this chapter ends
wow what a chapter and what a massive
new magic reveal we are now heading
towards the final climax in the fight
between yuno and xenon and once that
fight finishes and the final member of
the dark triad falls the focus is going
to quickly shift to a much bigger threat
and that is of course morris and the
cliffhoth devils oh and possibly the
fourth zogratis sibling will also make
an appearance but we'll have to wait and
see as i already said i think that star
magic will turn out to be a special and
extremely important part of this entire
arc since most magic attributes are
ineffective against devils once the
strongest devils emerge from the cliff
off the good guys will be in trouble
osta's anti-magic is extremely effective
against devils that is true but he has
multiple limitations he has to worry
about including the time limitations of
devil union so with that in mind we
can't expect asta to be the decisive
factor in every single major battle
going forward that means that other
characters who are capable of handling
even the strongest devils will have to
step up and it looks like that is
exactly what happened with yuno and the
appearance of star magic
let me know what you guys think are you
a fan of star magic as yuno's original
magic attribute and do you agree with me
that star magic as a celestial and
angelic type of magic could be the
kryptonite for devils is star magic
going to play a decisive role in the
final showdown of this arc and how cool
would it be to see yuno and asta
fighting together at full power against
lucifer or one of the other strongest
devils finally what are some unique
spells powers and abilities that you
think star magic is capable of
definitely leave your thoughts down in
the comments below i always love hearing
from you if you enjoyed this video and
you want us to keep it going with the
blacklover content don't forget to leave
a like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps a lot and if you're
new to the channel or maybe you watch
our channel but you just haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet it would help
me out a lot if you would take a couple
of seconds to subscribe hit that bell
and select the option that says all with
the way that youtube works going through
those steps is the only way to make sure
that you will actually see our videos in
the future you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a quick thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twigo himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
al-jatal
water the toasted chi the spike corey
mcgowan kaido might be a gyarados dylan
isidor spidey life tinel tungsten tarkis
big buddhist cody hebert monkey d quilly
and jeremy cummings finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red haired raven angel crews rafale
diora very gucci alicia actor bonnie
parks joy and garcia ted no ted and fat
boy games if you enjoy our videos and
you feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you